man himself he's also a medical doctor
kentucky senator rand paul
you've been right about this guy from
the beginning i'll be honest
i tried to give him the benefit of the
doubt there were a lot of things a lot
of people got wrong in the beginning i
thought
i never thought it was nefarious but we
now know
on january 31st that dr fauci was told
it looks like gain of function
uh manipulation of this virus the genome
of this virus
he was told that that happens to be also
the day
that donald trump put in place the
travel ban that's xenophobic and
hysteria
and 10 days after the first identified
case in this country
so you've been right the whole time
senator and unfortunately you've been
right
you know there's been no more prominent
uh scientist in favor
of gain of function research than dr
fauci he still hasn't backed off of that
position
he believes that it's okay to take
animal viruses
make them into super viruses to infect
humans
even if a pandemic should occur he says
oh the the research is worth it
but you know there's a host of other
scientists in this field
and they say it's not worth it at all
that we haven't learned anything
all we've done is put ourselves at risk
but even after all of this
evidence points towards the wuhan lab
this last week in committee dr fauci
said
that he still trusts the chinese
scientists and the thing is is that's a
very naive notion
that's how we got here but there are
worse viruses this is a bad one
this has about a one percent mortality
three and a half million people have
died
but they've been experimenting with some
viruses that have 15
mortality that would mean 50 million
deaths right now
so this this kind of research needs not
to be funded by the u.s taxpayer
and so i had an amendment this week that
passed actually unanimously saying no
more funds for this wuhan lab
so we'll see what dr fauci has to say
but he doesn't really have the judgment
to be in the position he's in
senator i hear the money uh that he is
saying
it was far much far much more in terms
of the actual dollar amount
do we have any idea how much uh money
american taxpayer money
went to fund this wuhan uh
virology lab and their gain of research
uh
uh function work
there's a lot of pools of money there's
a group called eco health alliance this
peter zonk
he's got a hundred million dollars over
the last several years now not all of
it's gone to wuhan
but they say as much as three to four
million may have
but there's lots of pots of money
there's defense money there's secret
money there's money we don't even know
about
because it's classified but this
research is being done in the united
states as well
it's very very dangerous and i want
scientists
that are not partisan to come to
washington so i sent a letter today to
the head of my committee in homeland
security
and also the health committee to say we
need to have a hearing with
impartial scientists who are on the
other side of dr fauci who believe that
it's incredibly dangerous
but you know what the other danger is
i've had five death threats just for
being outspoken on it this week i've had
five death threats
i don't know what the world is coming to
you can't ask honest difficult questions
that in the end have turned and proved
out that dr fauci was not being honest
with us
but as a repercussion my family had
white powders into our house and five
death threats phoned in
by the way been there sorry to hear that
it's not fun
i know it's happened to me it's happened
to many other people in the public
eye and it's it's it gets scary at times
uh and i hope you're getting the proper
security and i hope our government is
providing it to protect any politician
any elected official this is not
democrat or republican let me let me ask
you this
did dr fauci lie before your committee
absolutely he still says no money went
for gain of function research
one of the papers that he sent in the
emails that have come out
he labels the paper as gain of function
and that was at the wuhan institute
at the end of that paper the bat
scientist dr she
she thanks dr fauci's organization the
niaid which is part of nih
and she actually lists the serial number
for the money she got from the u.s
so he needs to be asked difficult
questions we need to have
other scientists there he hides behind
the veil of oh i'm the only smart person
in the room
no one else can understand this but many
other phd scientists
in this field completely disagree with
him and don't think it's worth risking a
pandemic
they don't think we should be doing
research and they haven't seen any
benefits of it either
i i think i recall that a gentleman by
the name of roger stone
um was charged with lying to congress
known as a process crime usually tells
somebody have your client report
at this location at this time and that's
the way it usually was handled
but he had almost 30 guys in tactical
gear frogmen
and fake news cnn cameras pre-dawn raid
guns drawn
for lying to congress is that a crime
it absolutely is a crime it's punishable
up to five years in prison
the thing is is no one's going to you
know dr fauci is going to
work around his words he's being very
careful with his words
it sounded like he was saying no money
went to nih but he was specifically
no money went for the wuhan institute
but he was being more precise and saying
no gain of function money went
but i think that's verifiably false also
but it's going to come down to an
opinion
he's going to say it wasn't gain of
function many other scientists are
already and have been saying for almost
a year now
that it all was gain of function but
he's not being uh
truthful he's not being completely
forthcoming he's shading the meaning of
truth he's parsing his words a real
problem
exactly and there's one other example
there's one other example i want to
bring up
right now india is struggling under this
they have a billion people
300 000 people there getting it they're
having about 4 000 deaths
dr fauci refuses to tell people that you
get immunity after you've had the
disease
this would allow the vaccine in india to
be targeted to those
who have not been sick but because dr
fauci says everyone's the same and
everyone should get the vaccine without
thinking about it
there's not enough vaccine to go around
in india so there are profound public
health implications
of dr fauci denying natural immunity
from the disease
in doing so i think it's leading to a
great deal of deaths around the world
that could be prevented and i believe
you were the first senator to go public
and say you had contracted covert
you have natural immunity you've made
the choice as your own doctor
not to get the vaccine in light of the
natural immunity t-cell immunity stuff i
don't know about but
i think people uh need to pay very close
attention because what's happened here
and by the way even therapeutics that
were advised to
dr fauci he ignored those emails it's
too long to read but
great work senator thank you for being
with us we appreciate it